Grigori Gusakov and Anatoly Korneev, both
aged ten, tiptoed through the deep, dark woods
bordering their quaint Russian village of
Obrechennyy.
The year was 1990, a turbulent time for the
people of Russia, seeing as the Soviet Union
was on the precipice of collapse.
But for these two young boys, global geopolitics
was the last thing on their minds.
They were too busy hunting for the legendary,
monstrous witch known only as Baba Yaga.
For those in our audience who grew up in Eastern
Europe, or those at least decently familiar
with Slavic Folklore and/or the John Wick
film series, mention of the name Baba Yaga
likely sends a slight chill down your spine.
And if it doesn’t, just wait.
By the end of this video, you’ll be afraid
to go into the woods alone.
Not that going with others would save you,
as poor little Grigori and Anatoly were about
to find out the hard way…
They forged on through those witchy woods.
By our standards, the boys were tough and
headstrong.
After all, the Russian wilderness could be
a brutal place to grow up, and in a town like
Obrechennyy, the old ways of stoicism and
perseverance were prized over fear and caution.
All except for one particular area: The Supernatural.
Like many small villages all over the world
at every point in history, Obrechennyy had
its fair share of local superstitions.
Chief among them was the belief that the local
forest was enchanted, and that when people
wandered in among the trees, many of them
would never return.
They’d fall into the gnarled clutches of
the carnivorous witch Baba Yaga, and their
bones would lay among the roots and dead leaves
until they someday crumbled into dust.
It was starting to get dark out.
The air was cold and thick.
When the two boys had first set off, it’d
been with the intention of proving their mettle
among the other local children.
They didn’t fear Baba Yaga; the old witch
in the woods was just another fairy story
meant to frighten children, and they weren’t
children anymore.
Though they would never live to be men.
It wasn’t long before they were beyond the
point of no return.
Which way was out, and which way was further
in?
It hardly mattered anymore, as carrion birds
cawed far above.
The bravado that put them here was starting
to falter now, but neither dared show it.
They’d rather be put in mortal peril than
show fear in front of one another.
Was something moving in the distant shadows?
A thin, twisted, human figure, impossible
to make out save for the faint glow of its
eyes in the gathering dark?
They couldn’t tell what was real and what
was their mind playing cruel tricks on them.
A hoarse whisper issued through the brittle
trees in the moments that followed.
It was an ancient voice, a voice that had
echoed in the nightmares of generations, a
voice that had seen centuries.
It spoke in an older Russian dialect than
either of the young boys could understand,
but somehow, the essence of its message still
rung clear in their hearts and minds.
“Welcome, little children, to my forest.
Here, your lives are forfeit.
You are my property.
I look forward to chewing the tender meat
off your young bones.”
That was all they needed to hear to start
running.
Gregori and Anatoly turned and fled, screaming
for help, into the darkness of the forest.
Both gasped as they ran through what seemed
to be a giant spider web.
They spat and spluttered, trying to swat away
the silky strands as they ran from the voice.
Little did they know, what they’d just run
through was no spider web.
They tried to press on, but their footsteps
slowed.
The forest was changing around them.
Twisting, shifting, sparkling.
What had seemed terrifying before was suddenly
oddly...beautiful.
The two boys just stood and watched as the
forest turned into a gorgeous Technicolor
light show, unlike anything they’d ever
seen before.
Strange figures hopped and danced through
the foliage.
One tall figure approached them out of the
trees.
A beautiful, fair-haired maiden.
The two boys were entranced by her.
Their hearts were filled with pure golden
light.
Why were they running before?
They couldn’t even remember.
They just smiled as the woman approached them
in her long, flowing dress, smiling back.
She was like something out of a fairy tale.
They didn’t react.
They didn’t even realize what was happening,
as the jaws of the horrible, ancient old crone
closed around their skulls for the last time.
Grigori and Anatoly were never seen again.
Just another two children gone missing in
the woods, the latest entries on a long list
of tragedies to hit the village of Obrechennyy.
But they were also the straws that broke the
camel’s back.
The villagers were sick of living in fear
under the fabled witch.
They would have their revenge.
The men of the village gathered up their weapons
and formed a hunting party.
Guns, torches, knives, axes, and fury.
They would slay the beast that had taken so
many of their friends and their children in
the woods.
As soon as their forces were assembled, they
charged into the forest, looking for blood.
With their numerical advantage and single-minded
determination, it didn’t take them long
to find the monster in the woods.
She was every bit as hideous and nightmarish
as they’d anticipated: A gnarled, snarling
crone, with long, clawed fingers and dirty
fangs.
They got her in their sights and prepared
to open fire, but none of them were ready
for Baba Yaga’s counteroffensive.
She moved like a leaf in a strong wind, swift
and effortless.
The men who’d made the mistake of getting
too close to her with knives and axes tasted
her terrible wrath.
She tore through them with claws like iron.
Sank her fangs into their flesh.
Lifted and tossed them like rag dolls.
How could she be so fast and so strong?
The men were terrified.
This was no mere woman.
It was a true monster, squeezed into a barely
human form.
By the time the creature was finally incapacitated,
it’d taken countless bullets and strikes.
How any creature could survive such an assault
was unimaginable.
Several members of the hunting party were
dead by this point.
Others had been overtaken by a strange form
of madness.
A couple of them had been given to constant
giggling fits or were speaking long strings
of nonsense.
Others had been rendered entirely catatonic
by the experience.
It was clear that the witch had powers beyond
their understanding.
They needed to return it to the village and
destroy it as quickly as possible.
The monster was bound and dragged back to
Obrechennyy.
After seeing how it bewitched some of the
men, they avoided direct contact whenever
possible.
They would do everything they could to see
justice done.
Of course, there would be no due process for
Baba Yaga.
The violence that had erupted in the forest
was more than enough proof to justify the
beast’s immediate death sentence.
The local priest gave a prayer - though he
remarked that he was sure this monster was
the creation and servant of the devil - and
the execution commenced.
A local used a blessed sword, anointed with
holy water, to hack off the Baba Yaga’s
head.
Its body was shot several times for good measure,
and it was finally doused in gasoline and
set on fire.
The remains were buried just outside the village
limits, hoping that the Baba Yaga’s evil
wouldn’t continue to haunt their town, even
in death.
Isolated villages in the Russian steppe aren’t
famous for their communication with outsiders,
especially back in 1990, when the Soviet Union
was still clinging on to control and the internet
was still in its infancy.
It took a few weeks for the news of a village
capturing its so-called local witch to reach
the SCP Foundation.
After closely studying the peculiar disappearance
records in the area, they sent over a detachment
of field agents to investigate, and perhaps
conduct a few interviews with the locals.
They had no way of knowing there wouldn’t
be any left by the time they arrived.
When the field agents reached Obrechennyy,
it was already a ghost town.
Not a single survivor was found, only the
evidence of fresh carnage.
Desiccated bodies were found in some of the
village’s houses.
In others, only body parts.
A hole in the ground next to the village seemed
to show evidence of some subterranean creature
clawing its way back up to the top.
Whatever this creature was, it’d clearly
crawled back up from the earth and exacted
bloody revenge against those who had buried
it.
Blood trails from some of the bodies leading
back into the woods made it clear where the
creature had fled to after massacring the
entire village.
Given the sudden increase in the situation’s
severity, Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6, aka
The Village Idiots, were brought in to apprehend
the fugitive witch.
But much like the literal village idiots that’d
come before them, this MTF had no idea what
they were up against.
They entered the forest outside Obrechennyy
with superior tactics and weaponry to the
villagers, with orders to contain the creature
at all costs.
They didn’t exactly know what they were
searching for in the dark amongst the trees,
but when the first operatives laid eyes on
the twisted old crone, they almost reflexively
relaxed their guard.
For some of the Village Idiots, this would
be the last mistake they ever made.
Some of the operatives began to feel funny.
Much like Grigori, Anatoly, and some members
of the hunting party, they began to see the
forest warping and shifting around them.
They giggled at all the funny colors, and
sighed, feeling an overwhelming sense of calmness
and euphoria.
It was honestly the best they’d felt in
years.
Perhaps they were wrong about hunting the
witch in here.
Maybe the real anomaly here was a Russian
forest that made you feel awesome when you
stepped inside.
While the affected agents were giggling away
in their own little la la land, Baba Yaga
was bringing the pain.
With the same freakish speed, strength, and
ferocity that had surprised the hunting party
weeks earlier, the witch was tearing through
MTF Epsilon-6, ripping through hardened tactical
armor with her long claws and teeth.
She took shot after shot, enough tranquilizer
to put down an elephant, but she kept fighting.
In the end, the training and numerical superiority
of the task force won out.
They were able to secure and contain the Baba
Yaga, soon redesignated SCP-352, and take
it to a nearby Foundation containment site
for further studies.
There they officially recorded all the details:
From the creature’s incredible speed and
strength to its regenerative ability so extensive
that it could even survive being decapitated
and burned.
But what about the hallucinogenic effects?
Like a hungry spider, the Baba Yaga’s true
power comes in her ability to spin a deadly
web.
Her body is able to produce long, thin, hair-like
fibers, each one coated in powerful hallucinogenic
enzymes that induce a sense of placid, euphoric
stillness in its victims.
When it isn’t engaging multiple targets,
the creature can sometimes take multiple days
to consume a single, still-living victim,
taking them apart and eating them piece by
piece.
Speaking of eating: As you can probably imagine,
in order to keep SCP-352 uneventfully contained,
it’s ideal to make sure it isn’t hangry.
In order to keep 352 well-fed, they need to
stock up on its favorite food, human flesh.
Though specifically, 352 has a real hankering
for babies.
While the Foundation are currently exploring
anomalous means of keeping the Baba Yaga fed,
until those means are fully ironed out, they
need to keep this monster fed the old-fashioned
way - only ever withdrawing food as punishment
if it attempts to breach containment.
After all, there’s a very good reason why
parents and children across the Slavic world
fear Baba Yaga.
She’s always hungry, and in the end, she
always gets what she wants...
Now go check out “SCP-3999 - I Am At The
Center of Everything That Happens To Me”
and “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885 - Find Him”
for more of the most frightening anomalies
out there!